in five four three two one welcome
everybody to another episode of the
genius brain podcast we have very we
have one special guest today and then we
have this piece of [ __ ] right here dude
man I thought you were gonna say I was
the special guest
no you're just special you jackass in a
good way we have Patrick T Riley what up
what is T stand for Thomas have the
whitest name of all Tomas what you've
been up to dude just chilling man just
working doing stand-up being a Papa you
know just the same just struggling those
[ __ ] balls this weekend you're a
[ __ ] dead man no fault I forget
sometimes to this person's life depends
on me one of those dads is put your kids
on top of the car just drive but my is
so good she'll hold on the whole car
right so hold on yeah he's a good kid
how old is your daughter she's gonna be
2 next month oh she's almost two yeah
she hella mean now hmm she's kind you
get a little [ __ ] sometimes bar she's
cool but sometimes I'm like yeah like I
just sit her down like you stop being
such a [ __ ] she's like you know what
you're right thank you for explaining
something you know we could be friends
but you're just a [ __ ] [ __ ] man
[ __ ] little kids do it like I just
went camping this past weekend and it's
funny because I think like when you
really like a kid they don't bother you
as much but if it's like I realized it
was somebody else's kid if it wasn't
like one of my close friends kid I think
I woulda hated that kid oh yeah but
because he was asking me he goes off my
our kid was really annoying right that's
like no man like he didn't bother me at
all but then I had to think about I was
like yeah if you were a random kid I
think I want a [ __ ] punted you like a
football yeah absolutely that love that
keeps you from abusing children yeah
that's the thing is like you don't love
other people's kids you're like who's
this annoying little [ __ ] that's just
crying and like asking for [ __ ] all the
time
oh they're so cute right Zev they say
it's like if they're not if your kids
aren't cute you're gonna choke your kid
I [ __ ] pray to God my kids ugly dude
that [ __ ] would be so [ __ ] funny
because Bart's kids [ __ ] cute right
tie is hugely cute and we have another
friend named and his daughter is hella
cute and my kid is ugly aw dude that'd
be so [ __ ] funny
my own kid the whole time dude as I
watched out the creature's cover I think
that if they would pretend like my kids
cute I'd be so upset they're gonna
they're gonna have the lowest
self-esteem as soon as they get older no
no they I wouldn't tell them that when
they're coherent okay [ __ ] yeah just
seeps into the subconscious yeah so they
know that they [ __ ] when they're [ __ ]
really young I would never say that when
they speak like English and [ __ ] now I
do yeah he's cool
yeah my mom's from Mexico like she's
she's so I'm like first generation on
her side but it's crazy because I look
so [ __ ] white like I didn't get any
of the Mexican looking jeans at all like
I don't know how that's possible yeah I
thought I was adopted for a while like
kind of like they were just never saw
pregnant pictures of my mom there was no
pain my name is Patrick Thomas Riley I
yeah what the [ __ ] did ya I don't know
they they wanted to give me like a
Mexican like Spanish type name like
Ricardo or something like that - they
were gonna so much they almost named me
Rafael so I would have been a file I
would have been douchebag Rafael Riley
but yeah so so I speak Spanish I catch
people off-guard all the time they're
like what the [ __ ] like that's dope
though when you don't look a certain
ethnicity you could always catch the
conversations about you that they don't
[ __ ] know about it happens all the
time because people definitely always
talk [ __ ] about me in Korean and I write
to my [ __ ] face so clearly I'm Korean
you sons of [ __ ]
you're the most Korean looking dude I'm
as goofy as it gets yeah I did this I
did the show out in Houston he's like
good morning Houston and it was for the
sin food [ __ ] and then I was reviewing
footage of myself at huh that's a [ __ ]
es face that says Asian as it [ __ ]
gets dude like I never seen somebody
look so Asian in my life dude I look
like a backorder Chinese cook dude like
when I was like son of a [ __ ] dude they
could've picked somebody as Asian as
possible they're like they let you on TV
I don't they should just call this thing
gooks I've been [ __ ] like when you
seem like a guy like Yoshi on TV you're
like okay
yo she looks racially ambiguous yeah he
does yeah it does he lookin like he
could be a brown guy for all we know I
think he's I think he's ethnically
Chinese but he's [ __ ] what's that
other [ __ ] he's Indonesian what's other
nonsense out to my Indonesia people your
language is [ __ ] ridiculous
shout to my fam you're Indonesian part
and part I think part what I heart you
tell you I was on my Singaporean side on
my mom's Singapore with my grandma I
don't know dude my grandma my grandma is
she's part Indonesia and part Malay was
my lai yeah Malaysian Malay no no dude I
just made all that up
my name is whiter than your name almost
not Jia Rong
that's my gr wrong what's your middle
name dude that's it here Robert this is
jean wrong yeah I can't even pronounce
it JAL wrong Sarang what's your name
I don't worry about nobody [ __ ] pigs
there's a guy with a hat and a blade on
it and that's like a pretty lame weapon
you know speaking of [ __ ] ugly Asians
did you see you see I got so my buddy
Khalif sent me this article so this is
dude that came on JK news really nice
guy the same is C mu Lu he's a part of
the show called Kim's convenience kim's
convened i got a pretty hot guy so check
this [ __ ] out right so this is youtube
okay
I'm pretty sure he doesn't find it funny
but he has to find humor in this because
it's pretty [ __ ] funny there's this
YouTube channel really popular called
Asian boss right and this is a guy that
he just walks around asking people
questions about Asian topics and so the
asian topic was is seemly lu handsome
and he's asking people in china and they
all things he's but [ __ ] ugly of them
interviewing chinese people and they're
like no I don't think he's attractive at
all every time American director by the
way there's your speaking Chinese I'm
just doing this for the actual effect
a Chinese American Hollywood choose
ugliest Chinese guy my money's a
handsome [ __ ] yeah but I guess I'm
Chinese standard he's too [ __ ] ugly
what is handsome too Chinese standards
they kind of gave a couple examples of
like handsome Chinese men that could
have filled that role for his Marvel
film who's a pic do they give it a shot
I you you would know their faces when
you've seen them but they're pretty
[ __ ] like me
yeah there's Gucci as it gets and I was
like oh I don't really consider that
very good-looking but I guess like
that's American versus Western style
yeah so one girl she gave him a 3.5 out
of 10 Wow so this fool seemed who just
woke up one day and had a whole video
about how ugly is how his own people
think he's [ __ ] hideous he shudders
he's Chinese I thought he was Corinne oh
man his name is Seema Lou yeah whatever
dude what kind of Korean name is that I
know plenty of people with like Korean
people with Chinese last names and it
throws me off
like what like Kwan yang Yang yeah
that's a Chinese name I guess
yeah we're neighbors though you're so
[ __ ] dumb dude one of my clients shut
out but this girl was hot it was like
this one girl was going [ __ ] in on
him dude she was just like oh my God
look like this guy man he's not even
handsome I came in 3.5 wake up and I see
him my [ __ ] dry up said that [ __ ] I
don't even know what the why why people
find him so unattractive in China first
off why are they making videos about if
somebody is handsome or not who gives a
[ __ ] he's handsome let it let it be who
cares
do you know what he looks like I don't
know if you have your phone on you he
kinda okay I wanna see becomes like me
but just you know a little bit like well
then they're right then he's hideous
yeah coming from a guy who looks like he
just woke up and masturbated hey man
there you go C mu C mu s I M you die no
no spell it okay well let me just I just
wanted to make sure since male
Singaporean Chinese I don't know what
the [ __ ] you are male it's for this says
random [ __ ] because I'm Elaine and I can
talk to him this dude is handsome
because you don't ask you don't ask
questions about me yeah this is him this
is him let me see
pastors like this exercise you know why
they're Asian dude you know why they
don't think he's hands
though I already know right off the bat
so Asian people has diffic good-looking
dude yeah Asian people have this thing
about beauty standards where your face
has to be small and he has a [ __ ] fat
face his face is fat as [ __ ] this is
shredder compared compared to what Asian
people like so easy people like your
face which is very small so a little old
Asian lady will come up to be like oh my
god your face is so small and that's the
highest compliment you can ever get an
Asian girl
thanks I know like I don't know what
that means but that's like a big
compliment but he has he has that wide
Guk face oh yeah that's actually true
now I'm thinking about it like Asian
people do find the weirdest things
attractive about somebody like really
asian people yeah now I think about
other things like my mom said to me
growing up it's starting to make sense
like what she said she says talk about
like how big my ears were like that's a
thing but I feel like your mom was
making fun of you because your mom talks
a little [ __ ] mom the way the way he
talks about his relatives in front of
his mom is so [ __ ] funny dude well
get your Bob just like yeah my scissors
are stupid [ __ ] and your mother don't
talk about your sister that way and by
the way your mom's English is fantastic
threw me off I'm telling it's cuz she's
from Singapore they all speak English
yeah we get it you're from Singapore
dude all right god it's like hey dude
[ __ ] to be more cultured David so if
I ever wanted to learn outside of school
and I wanted to continue my education
yeah we're talking about Skillshare baby
your this podcast is brought to you by
skill shine you guys know me I love
skill [ __ ] because I love learning at my
own pace now Skillshare has a collection
of lessons for a lot of people out there
that want to continue their education
outside of just institutionalized
education my friends we're talking about
online learning and the reason why I
love it so much because number one I get
to learn at my own pace for the things
that I want to learn how I want to do it
because that was the hard part for me
when I was in college right I had to sit
in class and I had to learn when they
told me to learn and it wasn't at my own
pace and so Skillshare provides your
pace of learning whenever you want with
their huge
library of collection of knowledge my
friends so Skillshare is an online
learning community with thousands of
amazing classes covering dozens of
creative and entrepreneurial skills you
can take classes in everything from
photography and creative writing to
design productivity and a lot more so
whether you're returning to a longtime
passion project challenging yourself to
get outside your comfort zone or simply
exploring something new Skillshare has
classes for you so join the millions of
students already learning on Skillshare
today with a special offer just for my
listeners get two months of Skillshare
for free that's right Skillshare is
offering genius brain listeners two
months of unlimited access to thousands
of classes for free to sign up go to
Skillshare dot-com slash brain again go
to Skillshare dot-com slash brain to
start your two months now that
Skillshare dot-com slash brain all right
you know what I like doing on this
podcast what I like saying guk alot yeah
Google is a great word just because I'm
allowed to say it it's like my version
of the N word you can't say it can you
patrick said yeah nobody cares no mad
that like that guy is saying that guy
that guy right there there are certain
people who find that word highly if I
just never grew up with that [ __ ] that's
why so to me it's just a funny [ __ ]
word nobody ever came out to me growing
up it was like I feel like it's like an
older word to write like it's past it's
like people don't say that anymore like
it's past its prime yeah it's expired
yes during the during the Korean War
that would have been like what the [ __ ]
dude you call me a [ __ ] has a dance
fight but nowadays it's fine I mean let
me ask you something know what you're a
straight man it seemed Alou was what
seemed to lose a handsome rating from 1
to 10 what do you give him
um I I think I'd give him like a 7 or 8
I guess damn it's pretty hot about you
like it 7.5 I'd say yeah but you know
but like Yoshi
Yoshi's up there yo she's handsome he's
a tan bro we'll be training sometimes
I'll be looking and I'm like bro we went
we went to go eat yesterday and this
lady was just like
the server was really nice but she was
extra nice she was like fumbling over
her words a little bit she was hanging
she was hanging around our table a
little too long I think she gave us like
free [ __ ] well you know I was also
sitting next to you she said you
couldn't tell who it was I think that
torn rotator cuff got her dude I tore my
rotator cuff just holding tougher
punches quick training tip if you don't
want that to happen just strength train
what is with you and strength training
because it helps everything do I suppose
been trying to give me the strength
train for the past like [ __ ] like
year times yes oh so yes what's up with
your torn rotator cuff okay man I'm
still punching people in the face though
huh how about that all right relax
punching people in the [ __ ] face ever
since started training you just want to
beat everybody up no that's not true
David is the most aggressive person I've
ever met
no out of the whole group David's number
one we're sparring that one time with
your Eddie as your manager right your
buddy attention to my opponent and I
just hear him go [ __ ] David not so hard
you see the size of his face is huge it
was his first day yeah and I told him to
slip and his face was so big if I still
hit it you guys ever seen the regular
show you ever seen the show with a
lollipop guy he's like this small a stop
at and that's what reminded me oh that's
exactly the size of his face here's the
thing about like age is that when you
were training with him it was his first
day mm-hmm and yours like I was really
good buddy right okay he never came back
okay well let me let me let me let me
put it to you like this
all right I've known him for my whole
life yeah deficits I was born and yet
some hate in your heart and when I was
younger
okay I used to be really annoying even
more annoying that I am now but I was
helpless and he was in football at the
time so I remember this [ __ ] he used to
be [ __ ] mad annoyed of me because I
used to always just [ __ ] around to
make fun of him a lot as a kid was three
years younger than him he once picked me
to the couch and punched my arms till I
couldn't feel them anything
so paybacks a [ __ ] that's why you have
a torn rotator cuff hey man that's your
[ __ ] hurt though dude yeah no you
were in some pain I felt really bad for
you
I was I was shocked how much been in
pain I was [ __ ] you know start train
who was hit in the midst who was
punching this guy I call mini Shane
phase in an arm rumor his name Jionni
Jionni James like you like a little 23
old guy he's a little handsome it's hard
another white use hitting a little
harder than I expected but then I think
well this [ __ ] was already feeling funky
for a while mm-hmm but the one time I
don't warm up and [ __ ] roll out and
[ __ ] look what happens
pop it goes tear I [ __ ] think see me
lose handsome as hell by the way
shoutouts to see what would you give him
I would give him a depends man shirt on
or shirt off a shirt on shirt on I give
him a I give him a 6.80 because we at
the compare until Yoshio was my next
question
yeah so if I compare him to Yoshi Yoshi
to me is a solid nine one about what I
was like nine he's up there I took my
mom to the the boba place the laboratory
right and Yoshi had an Indonesian drink
there that he was promoting and on the
menu
you see Yoshi's face and I was like look
ma no she I train with this guy and she
goes oh wow he's so handsome and I was
like did you just started say mom can
you stop doing that this sound that came
out of her mouth was like oh yeah you
just you want to make love to this yes
pain for sure yeah yeah in front of your
son which is weird
that's so [ __ ] weird yeah but she was
like oh my God he's so handsome and I'm
like yeah I know but he's alright hands
like what did you stop kickboxing I went
to school I went up to Santa Barbara and
I just wasn't training as much and also
like I started doing stand-up and then I
was like it I just liked it more and and
he started having sex with more women
that happened to the joke started
getting you more women like no I came
inside you what just kidding
but I just I wasn't like all in and I
knew that I wasn't all in and I I was
like I don't want to half-ass this cuz
like you can get in the ring get [ __ ]
up by somebody that is all in you know
so I just like I said moving it was a
combination of moving stand-up and not
being all the way in and then I just
yeah I just ran stand-up as I [ __ ] it
this is more me there's more my speed
you know how long were you doing
kickboxing for uh well total I've been
doing it for like ten years but like
really dedicated I was like five six
years and was like [ __ ] it every day
like every day yeah and then just like
it kind of started fading like the
passion I'll just like I still love it
but I didn't love it to be like a
professional athlete level of loving it
you know cuz that's what I thought at
first I wanted to do and then I was like
[ __ ] I'm not that into this you know
like I like sparring I like fighting I
like it all but you need to be like wake
up at 5:00 a.m. like running like eating
right all the time like you need to have
like that kind of mentality to really be
like I want to be in the UFC or want to
be a pro mmm glory fighter or whatever
the [ __ ] you know yeah yeah it's a
different level and it becomes work you
know as soon as you start doing it more
and more and then you have to worry
about getting ready for a certain date
to fight somebody you know I see you
fight so bad you don't get down dude I
remember the first the first time we I
saw him fight was at this place called
on Lake called pro boxing it was just
like a boxing store yeah and I had like
a ring in the back in the parking lot in
the back safe and we're spray was yeah
so safe so we were supposed to fight I
didn't get an opponent but I saw Nick
fight and Nick Nick always had like a
hard-ass [ __ ] opponent and he like
gets down super hard with this dude sick
as [ __ ] and then the next time we fought
we fought in a backyard on caulis in
Highland Park it was a backyard it was
like just some lady just had a barbecue
Oh Mike and then she's like hey guys it
was her Jill have some fights mm Cathy
long Cathy long was probably the most
decorated the female kickboxer at the
time and she still is she's like a
pioneer she was like oh wow
she's a beast like if you look her up on
YouTube she's a [ __ ] animal used to
beat the [ __ ] out of everybody so it was
her gym but it was in her gym and her
lesbian lover who was wearing a fedora
[Laughter]
as I was picturing every big there's a
lesbian lady and then a fedora pop our
head oh now I know what she looks like
visual information see cuz every time I
think about that lady I always think of
her with that hat on cuz she had that
hat on the whole time yeah and so we all
getting matched up dude it's so
nerve-racking I was so scared I was like
gonna throw up before my match you don't
know who you're gonna fight they just
show up there's a group of people like
you guys are about the same size you
guys are gonna fight your gear up in two
matches or whatever so I had seen Nick's
opponents spar before and I knew he was
a [ __ ] animal and like but we didn't
want to talk about it because it was
like Nick it was Nick's second fight I
think so no no I didn't want to be there
because the day couple date earlier that
week our coach was like hey we couldn't
find you a fight so you're not gonna
fight this Saturday so I was like all
right [ __ ] it I remember him telling me
he goes have fun in sparring today like
Oh like like let it out when I was like
all right cool so then I had like a we
had like a pretty hard sparring that day
right and I was like [ __ ] I kind of
really wanted to fight and then Saturday
morning I get a text message and I'm at
like we're at Pat's house he's like hey
like we found you a fight and I was like
ah that's the worst texting event by the
way like every time they didn't find me
a fight I was so happy I was like I want
to kick their ass but I wasn't gonna
find me where dude I had to pretend like
I was upset
ah dude go down there oh yeah we get
weighted types we get weighed in and
then we go back to Pat's house and we're
both just Pat sitting on his computer
desk and I'm sitting on his bed and
we're just both like waiting for death
row we're not talking at all we're like
a couple hours and we're just sitting
down we're looking up the ceiling and we
were sitting down for like two hours
just like shook we're like [ __ ] because
we didn't think we were gonna fight and
then sure enough they got us a match and
then it was all day we you guys have
footage of this [ __ ] yeah yeah there's
footage of my fight and this footage of
his fight his fight is really good so he
gets in the ring and they start mixing
it up and I think they got tags Nick
hard boom and it wakes Nick up and Nick
starts [ __ ] getting down like
when Knicks turns that flips that switch
he [ __ ] is like he's a savage dude
like he was he was getting down a har
like boom-boom-boom head kicks bang back
and forth back and forth and at one
point it hits him with a left hook a
meanness left hook in rocks him it was
like he turned into an animal that a
fight it was like I didn't want to we
were the last fight of the day we were
there for probably about six hours it
was like the middle of August it was hot
as [ __ ] if I like it wasn't Thailand and
I just wasn't ready for that at all and
then like as soon as we touch gloves I
was like I'm a very slow starter
naturally and I just kind of wasn't in
the mood to like fight I was just kind
of like very low-energy and as soon as
he rocked me he like closed one of my
eyes Oh like I got bruised Evan I'm
blind as a bat and he knocked out my
contact of my other eye so I couldn't
really see anything and he had me
[ __ ] hard and I was like oh [ __ ] this
guy's really trying to [ __ ] me up and I
grabbed him and I kind of had deja vu
like I felt like I dreamt about it
before and I get it a lot but it was
weird to have it right then and there
and I'd look and I see my buddy Frank in
the crowd and I see like TIFF and I was
like tripping the [ __ ] out I was like
whoa and then after that happened I was
like okay this is [ __ ] go time and I
was like dude if I don't like bring it
to this dude he's gonna [ __ ] me up and
it was a yeah it was a pretty crazy
fight the question is did you win yeah
Barry did talking about it and then
immediately threw up afterwards asked
the guy threw up in the ring and then I
had a throw up in the UH in the bathroom
cuz like I got like an exhaustion
headache because I was really dehydrated
and you were concussed to break I might
have been cuz but I think it might have
been like an exhaustion headache because
that's the the symptoms are very similar
you get really not hit hard dude like
he's hard
I remember him hitting you and being
like he was like five in one at the time
it was good they didn't tell me that I'm
glad I did it because I would have been
pry shook you know the weird thing is
like because watching a fight on TV
versus watching it in person two
completely different things it's fun to
watch it on TV watch
person is very nerve-wracking like when
I saw our buddy Rawdon when he fought
and I just saw him going to the ring I
was gonna throw up
oh yo why the [ __ ] am i nervous I'm not
fighting that's me and everybody getting
nervous there's me everybody it's like
your friend and it's a [ __ ] fight and
the other guy's an animal
yeah oh he's an animal like the stakes
are so high you're right it's like every
time Heinrich is about to fight and
we're in the back and we're about to
walk out I'm just like I'm like dry he
being in the back
Heinrich isn't even dry heaving he's
looking at me like hey dude can you cut
it out okay doc you keep it you're
messing with my head you keep like dry
heaving you know on the last podcast
when you were imitating Heinrich it was
like that is that's not what he sounds
like it actually is what he's more I
hang out with and I'm like I was wrong I
actually deleted his accent out of my
head he actually does sound like that
hey you trying to train or what
hey David when you [ __ ] hit that job
just throw a quick hook in the right to
the body we also fix your car and
pupusas yo shout-out to Heinrich you're
kicking me much we [ __ ] on them every
podcast is like a recurring theme I love
it but he kind of deserves it because we
love them but mmm he deserves it yeah
I'm willing to bring Heinrich on this
podcast soon bs4 and I want him to
defend himself both physically and
emotionally
I don't really appreciate it when you
guys make fun of my accent people think
of me you know the last time we were
training it was a Heinrich and then his
daughter was there and then Muriel my my
fiancee she wanted the Train but then
she was oh yeah congrats it's so funny
cuz like Mary was hanging out with
Heinrichs daughter like all she's super
fun she's super cute but the right when
the kids started turning on and she was
like do this do that do that she's like
can't you tell me what to do and I
looked around so you know you're an
adult right don't have to do it right
the fact that you got bullied by a
four-year-old kid is a little weird for
me man
I just said no I'm not doing it it's
like but she's she was pouting that she
could [ __ ] out yeah yeah yeah just
total [ __ ] off she'll be fine right dude
I wanted to do if I have a kid if I'm
gonna spank them dude that's how like
what my mom is with like my daughter
like my mom will just give her ice cream
all the time cuz she asked for ice cream
oh my god and she'd be like well she
wanted ice cream and it's like yeah dude
but not all day also the adult don't
give her sugar 24/7 yeah just like no
and she had you so she knows how to be a
parent that's the thing is I don't think
she does cuz like now I watch her and
I'm like damn no one I'm certain I like
put things together and like I'm like oh
this actually all might like my problems
it all makes them like it all that I
understand it completely because she
just lets it she's like yeah if I could
do whatever you want there's a wake-up
you get six lollipops and you stick in
your mouth yeah yeah my mom always give
my [ __ ] daughter sugar do it I had so
many cavities growing up I had like four
like legitimately at least thirty
cavities growing up like I remember I
want for like a couple years I didn't
have two front teeth because like but
there was cavities blocking like it was
a mess what the [ __ ] yeah my mom they
just gave me husband years now and then
she has the audacity to be like dude I
always fed you good like you yeah I gave
you healthy fluid like you ate
vegetables vegetables cause it was
cotton candy that was shaped into a
broccoli yeah yeah there you go like
[ __ ] dude
they were only like a we're just an
extension of what our parents are - it's
so funny cause like I think when I when
I was younger I was so adamant about
just tie my father like here not mom
never be like you and then I'll catch
myself doing my dad like [ __ ] dude I'm
just like a [ __ ] guy I used to hate as
a kid yeah even when I walk around the
neighborhood dude I walk her off my
hands around behind my back like an old
Asian guy did it's so disgusting like I
caught myself in my own reflection
walking by a store just walking on with
my hands behind my back that's the most
Asian [ __ ] ever yup and then you started
slapping your thighs as you walk by yup
and I started doing Tai Chi in the
middle of the street did [ __ ] um
Casey's wife TIFF told us that she we
talked about it on her podcast but there
was a guy but they were looking to go
buy houses that there was a dude
living next to them that was like hyper
[ __ ] racist
he didn't want them to move in so it's a
Chinese dude and a [ __ ] Mexican girl
with a little Mexican boy and they come
in and the moment they see him they walk
out with their Trump signs and face it
right towards them Wow flips it around
has that Trump thing and it has like
their [ __ ] uh make America great
again build a wall type of [ __ ] yeah
just face them and stared at them and
then as they as they were looking around
the house the guy just took his truck
and started peeling out around the whole
[ __ ] Jesus Christ dude they should've
sign the lease no that's what I said and
just to be like all right dude we're
gonna put the most Chinese [ __ ] I was
just starting [ __ ] up [ __ ] that's all
there dude
Peking duck smoked a cigarette in the
crouching stance Chinese chefs outside
right I'll just take my kid to start
beating them in front of them wow that's
[ __ ] insane dude the penny peeled out
like peeled out like that I'll show them
twice so he went they came back again
slurred around right again that guy has
a little dick that's a dumbass Animal
Kingdom [ __ ] like to like peel like you
know I mean that's the Evelyn's of like
a chimpanzee just screaming yeah his
head he's like he's like this will show
them I'm gonna scare them off and he's
gonna start peeling out like a [ __ ]
leaf [ __ ] is wrong with you people that
people out or they Rev their engines
really loud I don't want to say this but
I kind of hope they you know don't iced
any more yeah I hope they don't say died
yeah I hope they die knocking what but
like snow don't knock on wood I hope
they actually die yeah cuz that's the
root of [ __ ] ever was so crazy I just
don't understand how like why why like
what does it do what do you do yeah what
do you get from that like why do you
have to like what do you gain from
[ __ ] just hating these be like why
what did they do you know like what do
you think that they did to you that
deserves all that crazy-ass [ __ ]
well speaking from experience it just
makes you feel good about yourself you
think so when you're racist about two
other people you just feel good about
your son are you a racist Nick yeah I am
a racist yeah yes I am
I just I'm such a [ __ ] petty ass human
being though yeah I should do not like I
I would joke about it but I think I
would have bought that house I think I
just would have bought it just to piss
them off yeah I would have bought that
[ __ ] house I would wait till their
daughter's 18 years old and I would [ __ ]
her and I would literally [ __ ] the
living [ __ ] out of their 18 year old
daughter and then impregnate her and
then you would have to see my [ __ ]
little children you would have to call
them granddaughter or grandson and me
we'll call you grandpa grandma you gotta
trick the dad into thinking that he is
in love with you that's what you have to
do you have to slow like that one
documentary what's it called that
[ __ ] weird documentary where he gets
jerked off by the dad oh yeah do the
whole plain sight or something oh yeah
yeah I didn't even watch he told me the
story but once he like at first I was
like damn this dude sounds disgusting
but when you told me that he [ __ ] them
the dad - yeah I was actually the
gangster should ever burn all right the
daughters gross pedophile that's not the
mom like it's like okay yes and then he
convinced the dad to jerk him off
because he was tired or some [ __ ] it was
like man I'm really stressed out I've
been I've been fighting with my wife a
lot and we haven't been lovemaking him
I'm just in so much pain and he whips
his dick he's like man I just need some
release I think father moved that's he
pushed all the chips to his side of the
table and was like what's your move and
it worked
what's your move the guys like oh well I
guess I'll put my mouth on it he says he
jerked him off but it's like oh he did a
lot more than he for sure bang them it
was such a weird I didn't get to see the
whole thing but to understand what I
think he selected people who were very
closed off and very ignorant right so
they're just very very sweet dumb dumb
dumb people right just idiots just
[ __ ] just don't really see it Dumbo's
right yes I'm gonna happen to anybody
working at JPL want me to jerk you off
like thank you if you ask any normal
human being and somebody just comes up
as a Scot doing my [ __ ] relationship
with my wife is crazy can you suck my
dick your first reaction isn't like
he needs help yeah like and then the
here's the thing where I will whip so
that's such Midwest [ __ ] - I guess meant
like first of all how dare you do
Midwest people listen to this podcast
everybody cancel me no but like here's
the big like small town that's like
small town stuff because I mean well it
is nice they mean like you know what I
mean like yeah exactly they want to help
they want to know they're like this guy
obviously needs a blow job I'm here too
I have a mouth I can I can do something
about it like wow he's been a great
friend to me he took me record shopping
because I was a story they went record
shopping and then he pulled him up to
like a very romantic you know view and
then with that dick I was like hey man
I've been [ __ ] stressed
[Laughter]
cuz because all those guys that are like
predators they obviously you want to
find somebody that you could take
advantage of oh I would who would ever
try that with David oh because I would
give him the worst hand job ever dude oh
oh
I don't even jackoff myself is so
terrible I would hope that they have a
lot of foreskin - cuz I just [ __ ] I
would stretch it out this way I'm gonna
balloon it up and I put water in it I
meant I just fill it up with water and I
just let you play with it I would take
his foreskin I would fill it up with
water that I tied up like a water
balloon but it feels really good keep
going and then I would untighten and
slowly squirt the water ups kids this
Korean handjobs you guys did it now I
was extending out sir wait a [ __ ]
bite like a [ __ ] strings and like a
string instrument do you make some like
beautiful notes
no I'm okay I don't need this [ __ ] no
you do want this play like that annoying
asian [ __ ] guitar
[Laughter]
was he he wasn't a serial killer though
now he was a serial like a statutory
rapist I guess he's a sir so the whole
if you haven't watched it it's called
abducted in plain sight that's what it
is and I think he he kidnaps he makes
friends with his neighbors and they're
really good buddies
and he kidnaps the daughter is he the
one that convinced the girl about aliens
yes oh my god like he made a recording
saying that uh an alien voices saying
that you must recreate the population
with whoever's in the front of the RV
they're an RV she listened to it and
she's like 13 maybe maybe 11 or
something I don't know she's really
young I will say this though this is not
you know [ __ ] it if my daughter was 13
and that stupid that'd be so
disappointed yeah would be so [ __ ]
disappointed he was like oh he was right
how specific is that right also look at
parents I am an alien you need to have
sex with the bald man in the front if he
happens to be bald severe but ORV I
guess that's him my daughter's just like
oh yeah so she has sex with him because
she feels like she has to repopulate the
earth with this dude then let's go makes
sense the parents are like hey bring our
daughter back and they're like no then
the cops get him they bring him back the
mom has sex with the guy
after half after he's already abducted
that this guy is amazing that's what I'm
saying like nowadays like he's a
documentary about the dopest guy plays
side is called pimp gee master mm the
guy who [ __ ] anybody and everybody
family and the dogs got there everybody
they're interviewing the mom and she's
like still smitten with him she's like
yeah he was very handsome he was very
charming
I'm like bro
dude kidnapped your daughter audited
twice two times she made out with him
once she hooked up with him once and she
was like oh I can't I'm I'm married to
you gets kidnapped the daughter gets
kidnapped
mom bangs the guy I can't remember if
the dad got jacked off before or after
the daughter got kidnapped I think it's
time or it was before but like then he
kidnaps her again brings her to Pasadena
pasadena' pasadena all my Pasadena um
but yeah he kidnapped her twice and like
she still want to have a relationship
like they're very well a lot of trauma
very damaged people of course but also
just be called the dumbest family on
earth yeah people are very [ __ ] of
all you know when you watch that you're
like oh man
these people but also don't have sex
with a guy that raped your daughter you
know yeah yeah clearly I don't have to
say that I feel like they've at that
time - they probably never met an Asian
person I feel like I could have came up
to them and said well in Asia what we do
when we meet each other is that we [ __ ]
the wife in the mouth and they would be
like oh yeah yeah and if you don't drink
my [ __ ] it's very offensive yeah already
makes you a way better person this man
yeah there you go it's actually what
royalty do she would have said okay you
ever see the movie Mulan and yeah that
[ __ ] great how long ago was this was
this like in the 70s probably I think
they were they were they were definitely
in the Midwest I don't know where
exactly but they were in the Midwest I
said why and he replied with where this
[ __ ] dumb guy dude stupid ass I just
asked you when depends on the location
location dude time is just a fabric of
our imaginations yeah there you go you
got it boom you don't have to respeet
did he get arrested he drank glue he
drank Lee when he killed himself this is
not a real story dude dude this is
so he started he started a summer camp
no he did he started a summer camp yeah
he started selling this you're not
really you know like like where they
have a lake and they have like a big
giant blob where people jump yeah yeah
yeah but it was started dick come on
kids jumpers are horseshoe go ahead jump
I'm ready
go ahead and all their parents signed
off on everything they're like yeah
that's this boat yeah and he like
assaulted like five other kids while he
had his summer camp oh my god and then
she the daughter wanted to move out
there with him and though the mom sent
her she's no I go didn't have kids like
the daughter and the oh no but she wrote
up as she got older she wrote a book
about the whole thing talking about like
trauma how it affects people and
Stockholm Syndrome type of thing if I
was that girl I would never write a book
about that [ __ ] cuz that is only proof
that I'm really dumb like I'm not it's
like a product of her trauma you know
because she was like 11 yeah man I'm not
I'm not minimizing the fact that it was
very traumatic but you know what as a 13
year old you get a pass
yeah you're tearing your parents don't
get a pass yeah parents are 100%
literally the worst your parents were
the worst parents on earth and on top of
that you said that what she was talking
about the dude she was like drooling
over him yeah she was in she's like 70
or 60 something and she's talking about
him and she's still like wet off because
I only saw up to the point where the guy
was telling the story about how he gave
the better dude a [ __ ] and I started
died how are you you got married you got
to finish it all the way and I started
questioning myself I was like is this
supposed to be a sad moment it's
supposed to be funny it was cracking the
[ __ ] up cuz in the interview he's he's
crying and it's it's sad it's really sad
but it's also like it's really sad but
it's also you're very upset at this guy
oh I'm super upset yeah cuz you're like
a terrible parent don't I don't know I
would never jack off another dude will
say out that yeah Yoshi Yoshi Yoshi was
like man I really need some release in a
Tesla so that's like ice modeling to
skin stress
relax watch this [ __ ] though this is
this is the true question alright I
asked this to everybody and everybody
has a price what is the lowest in
dollars oh wow okay what is what is the
lowest amount of money that you'll take
to suck a dick
damn unless you've not to completion
just like Oh a little bit I call it five
five swipes Gorgon style like that
you got a cradle balls to like that
you got a grab ball you know honestly
I'm afraid to say this but it's uh pride
not that expensive boys that number
tunnel I really don't know how thousand
dollars no I wouldn't do for a thousand
five thousand dollars mm probably not is
your life right now all right what's
going on depends on what state I'm in
you know five hundred dollars and I'd be
like hey will you pay for the wedding
okay cool if some guy was like I'll pay
for your wedding but you just have to
like your father's like like all the way
to the back of the throat five times
like my dad also gets to grab your head
in the back because I have to hear skin
to forehead contest yeah yeah yeah I
don't know watch your nose on my belly
button here's the thing I don't know
about that because I don't know if my
I'm not that confident in my abilities
to do that cuz I never tried it thirty
thousand dollars the fact that you have
to think about it shows your trash dude
nah man way too low you [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ]
what's wrong with you it's for comedic
effect right the comedic effect my ass
did or the other guy's ass you [ __ ]
weird there's that here's a question I
always ask if gun in your head but
actually no no gun your head you have to
pick would you rather get like plowed in
the but this is a always ask at church
and yeah it's my mom my sisters
everybody clients my aunt's a mob real
quick Sears question cloud BS or finish
the dude off by you know sucking him off
to completion
Jesus I would definitely suck the dude's
dick oh dude no man what would you do no
they're both pretty rough why don't you
explain your reasoning why that's such a
I feel like a blow job is way more like
yeah but a blow job
you're in control the other one you're
getting [ __ ] in the ass you have to
get if you get to completion if you go
to completion why is why is one way if
the guy completely ass they're both yeah
completing a mind is he coming in my ass
is a question uh what did you want no
he's not completing in my mouth then
exactly that's the thing it's like I
would never I would never put a you suck
a dick you're in control though the
other one the guys grabbing your hips
and lifting you in the air is your
little tiny ass dude he's [ __ ] the
living [ __ ] are strong because I
strength trained pretty frequently so I
think I could finish them off pretty
quick second
I feel like putting a penis your mouth
is way more intimate and I'm not really
about that but you could but see here's
the thing though cuz there you could
easily versus you have to like taste
that's weird
honey I would just eat a bunch of ice
cubes if that [ __ ] out you didn't tell
me how I have to do it and on top of
that I would make him shower thoroughly
now you can take you just beat us you
can't get easy and what age whatever you
want choose your own adventure at this
point it's use my home it's swiping
through dick yeah this one I'll go with
this so you would rather get what about
you he won't pig is so hard to actually
think about that here's the thing yeah
you have to answer it
um there is no bush so you'd say you'd
finish a dude off by suckin amok but I
think one is think about how much work
when I actually think about it I just
it's like so horrific for me that I like
both are her lame dude you're still
aiming I'm gonna pick I'm gonna pick I
think he's not gonna pay my parents are
so proud of us right now Holly everyone
everyone in the comments is gonna be
took they would alright a lot of
comments have that [ __ ] if you're
about to answer if you're a hetero male
you have to answer what are we doing
here if you're not hmm answer it I think
I would go with suck I think it's suck a
dick dude really you know why because
he's a [ __ ] man and you're a little
[ __ ] that's why you would get [ __ ] in
the butt dude he would be like going
home
on your ass I'm talking about he would
grab your hipbones yeah and just I'm
looking over there like he would [ __ ]
you so hard from the back your eyes will
pop out like a Acme cartoon yeah you'd
be like slow down do I shut the [ __ ] up
now what's your [ __ ] dick sucking
price now it's I don't know man I'm not
really down five hundred thousand for
five pumps five pumps no I please just
head back of the head I feel like that's
not asking a lot so is that a yes you
would do it for 500,000 realistically
yeah realistically man I think I might
think I'm gonna think about it I'll take
a day 600,000 we're here already I would
say let's just go for the mill but I
don't think I'm you know like I'm not
making that you're not making the
conditions olav is Ola the the angry
Russian Russian man he's my wife seven
hundred and fifty thousand dollars I
probably I'm definitely leaning towards
yes the only reason why I'm asking is I
need to say this now you're [ __ ] gay
spectrum bro and I knew it you should
have came out the closet 750 thousand s
[ __ ] low dude is it I don't know man
Patrick butcher no tax free okay we're
talking taxes we're going to tax rate in
a suitcase sick sequential sequential
sequential completion sequential damn
bro I don't have a million a million
dollars then 1 million more untaxed see
the thing is is like it sound like like
even like 10 million dollars dude 5 be
like janus much money you set my life
but then actually getting into the room
and the guy banging all right here we go
and he like unzips a little bits a dick
up he's like Hello five months is not
hello hello my pumps that's not that
much but made nutshell a little quite
while but needs five pumps for two
million
ask for more first of all
just by this conversation later I
respect Patrick way more than you
because where he got second you know but
I said a billion he was like are you
[ __ ] kidding me you I said five
hundred thousand you went Wow ninety
bucks you piece of [ __ ]
hey man this is this is who we are baby
750 K that's not bad that's not bad nah
dude for five cuz every time you'd spend
that money you would like every bill
like you'd have that money for a while
and you'd be like damn I see that was
him self respect for this for this defy
Express million dollars no dude I don't
think so forty million it would have to
be the only way that I would consider it
is if it was like you literally never
have to work like you won't have money
for the rest of your life and never have
to work again that's the only where I
would like Ted you're a [ __ ] prude
ten million dollars dude that's you'll
never let's let's make fun of Patrick
revoir what a prude E is am i right yeah
this guy's a [ __ ] you know I did you
guys are like on the opposite spectrum
because you know cell procedure too much
self-respect
Tiffany would be mad at me I said that's
crazy how much would it take you how
much money o me a solid 12 cents I think
it would be a good like if I wasn't
being realistic really would change my
life yeah first of all I already asked
Muriel if it's okay and she said no but
she's just so [ __ ] dumb because it
wasn't change our whole lives because
he's not even coming in my face or
anything dude it's just five level super
fast five pumps they obviously need an
obstacle that [ __ ] disappears like that
yeah I would do it for easy eight
million because I think eight million
can change my life and I don't have to
work well you have a great big social
media following to so that's that's a
good thing if it is supported and people
had to see the video easy it has to be
like 20 million cuz then I'd live with
that shame right I'll be living in that
[ __ ] for traveling if somebody if
somebody saw saw that I would go way up
more than that if it was on the over
100,000 you traveling to millions to
more can't two thousand dollars more and
then you get
upload it and put it on the hub whoo
damn come on man you walking that you
walk into a coffee shop everyone's like
this guy has no value to himself as a
human being
yeah if nobody sought Oh every everybody
sees this video now what's your price oh
dude I'm talking easy though 100 mil
hundred mil damn really yeah what from
[ __ ] 750,000 well this is behind
closed doors dollars a face so bad he's
like any other 1000 was was to
completion there was not to completion
yeah the person was for completion now
you're making [ __ ] up oh I'm [ __ ] you
never say completion elation this will
literally said no easy 100 million now
you guys are changing your life his
number would be a hundred million cuz he
has a lot of self-respect also clearly
he doesn't care about his daughter
honestly like hey your dad's a
[ __ ] you like the wrong reason
it's like dad did you really suck dick
yeah do you have clothes on your back
you stupid little [ __ ] like this
mansion yeah yeah you know what
these lips daddy suck dick for this
mansion I will [ __ ] start selling
first just like daddy suck dick for this
mansion yeah you just you would have to
own it you'd have to like you can't
never like Charlie Sheen a mess-up dick
for money if everybody knew then yeah
you you have to go higher but if nobody
knew it's different it's very different
but then every time anyone mentioned
anything about like sucking dick you'd
be like you just begin to be in the
corner like blah blah it'd be really
awkward yes but if you're a wife like Oh
weird
if you're okay I think with my
personality type I'd be completely okay
with it okay with people clowning on me
for the rest of my life if I had 40
million dollars in the bank yeah that
makes it 150 K sounds not that much if
you say 40 and you know we're in this
world now where it's all about fluidity
and LGBTQA VT yeah yeah yeah so I'm
pretty sure that I would have a huge
amount of support saying you know what
dude
your flute your flu ID your socialized
[ __ ] man that's really progressive of
you and I'm you've come a long way dude
so thank you I still can't believe
you're number $750,000 that's actually
the lowest out of I've asked a lot of
people all your rich time actually I'm
not only i once even say seven hundred
thousand he said a cool two million so
you're really below oh that guy sleeps
outside of my house so I know yeah real
good
yeah and he's ashamed of you know Dan I
think Tiffany would be like just you're
not worth more than a millstone just go
750 K don't be like yeah you're bi yeah
you could marry your do she sounds great
k is my final answer
for now cuz money can really change your
life though like I I don't
it's weird I don't think I go around
life thinking too much about money but I
think as I get I'm getting older I am
thinking about money now it's like oh
[ __ ] like I mean for you you have a kid
I think about if I have a kid what if I
need to get a house and also the [ __ ] so
I freaked out a little bit now I'm like
well [ __ ] like maybe money is important
when it's not just you sure and then I
have a I have a fiance now so I'm like
oh what the [ __ ] I guess I should really
think about making money now ya know
it's stressful it's just as me
especially like having a daughter I'm
like [ __ ] dude like I got a food I mean
I want her to live good you know like
yeah it is it does put a huge weight on
you can I just say the transition from
how what we were talking about before so
where it's at now is just like a really
cool transition thank you
you're talking about sucking dick for
money and then how important money is
that is it that is that is important
that is the price that we need to pay
for our future children yeah you're
right cuz I don't think my kids would
mind you know honestly if you really did
get 40 million for sucking some dick I
don't think your kids in mind you did I
wouldn't they would just be like you
know yeah we got 40 minutes they
probably would though because they're
they wouldn't know any different you
know kids would be shown him the pornhub
video though at school it'd be like I
can't believe you did
that would be five plums Wow I know it
should be like up in the camera
afterwards 40 million though you know
they didn't see the edited video where I
was like my future children everything
you have is because of this I've been
five pumps and then the extra long
version is you like oh we might as well
just finish this off now and then the
back of juicy [ __ ] Vladimir and his
big old belly just walking around butt
naked man a little I just did it earlier
okay 45 million dollars in my bank John
now yeah that's pretty cool yeah I'll
buy the whole [ __ ] world well guys
that's this [ __ ] weird podcast and
I'd really dig can we leave in the
comments below say Nick do better
because that my friends yes very
disappointed backed yourself you know
that you care about you gotta know where
you're at now and then slowly you just
work your way up you gotta pay your dues
baby you need boss some money or what
you watch some Tony Robbins video okay
you buy some Gary Vee positive
affirmations in the morning in the
mirror you need to you need step it up
dude here's the thing it's just you know
I'm just a little more humble than you
guys that's all it is no you're little
you're [ __ ] weird yeah that's exactly
what that is well guys you catchy just
preying on iTunes Spotify whatever
podcast audio platform there is out
there and then on YouTube leave in the
comments below what you would do what a
price what's doing and by the way if
you're a girl you don't count cuz yeah
oh if you're a heterosexual woman you
don't count because because you do it
for free exactly that's a little
different so it's very different it's
quite different it's like it's like a
girl that sucks dick - she's a
germaphobe it makes distinction because
you do it for free
exactly so yes guys we talk about
serious topics on this real [ __ ]
changing the world type questions
actually going to be added to the
presidential debate this year so it's
Andrew yang I would like you to answer
this question it actually would be great
$1000 all like that like this out of
nowhere just in the presidential debate
so what do you think about the economy
like we needed
bring jobs back to America yeah yeah but
how much to suck a dick on camera and
then pops Adrian easy answer he goes
well $1,000 could really change your
life yeah right there see I'd be like
I'm voting for they get he handles most
humor handles curveballs well yeah
that's the president right there boom
that's why one all right guys we'll see
you